[Music]
the latter half of 2016 was all about
hardware for Sony but PlayStation 4
owners still enjoyed a respectable haul
of new games the consoles already strong
library grew even stronger thanks not
only to an embarrassment of top-tier
multi-platform games but also to several
quality exclusives including timed
exclusives like the witness and fire
watch console exclusives like Street
Fighter 5 and true platform exclusives
like Ratchet and Clank and res infinite
and those weren't even the best of the
best if you somehow slept through 2016
or just picked up a ps4 recently here
are the 5 most essential ps4 games that
launched this past year many games
strive to create connections between
their characters but none have achieved
anything quite as extraordinary as the
bond that gradually forms between Trico
and the nameless boy over the course of
a meter you ADA's at the Last Guardian
while most games build bonds through
static storytelling Last Guardian turns
relationship building into an active
process through the boy you must train
trico the same way you might train a
real-life pet slowly through a gradual
earning of trust
watching trekker react just as a real
animal might and overcoming the early
frustrations associated with coaxing a
stubborn creature to behave a certain
way creates an uncannily real connection
that's nothing short of magic add to
that an enchanting world and a
satisfying final act and you've got a
Sony exclusive worthy of team ICO's
legacy even if it took nearly a decade
to develop sony's other major exclusive
also suffered a few delays but just like
the Last Guardian uncharted 4 a thief's
end proved to be worth the wait
not only does it provide some of the
most intense and thoughtfully directed
action sequences ever it also manages to
layer nuance into familiar characters
and reframe our understanding of the
series as a whole all while drawing the
story of roguish explorer Nathan Drake
to a satisfying close from the expert
voice acting to the subtle visual
storytelling every element of uncharted
force presentation contributes to a
cohesive vision that's delivered with a
level of craftsmanship unmatched
genre in retro actively enhances our
appreciation of the previous games on
route to becoming the new best entry in
an already celebrated series arguably
the only major flaw with uncharted 4 is
its decent but forgettable multiplayer
thankfully that hasn't been an issue
since overwatch started dominating all
of our online time legendary developer
Blizzard Entertainment's first new IP in
17 years as well as the studio's first
shooter
overwatch took the long-standing idea of
class-based multiplayer and expanded it
to the extreme crafting a roster of 23
playable characters each material feels
distinct in every way
weapons movement abilities even their
roles on the battlefield differ
measurably yet somehow every character
is equally memorable regardless of how
you like to play you can find a favorite
that suits you and there's rity check
depths created by team composition alone
turn over watching to one of the year's
most exceptional online multiplayer
games
when we weren't busy over watching there
was another online shooter that
commanded our attention titanfall 2 the
ultimate example of a sequel done right
everything that made the original so
special remains the agile gravity
defying movement of the pilots the
earned empowerment of the Titans the
engrossing chaos of online modes
populated with both human players and
droves of AI fodder but in each case
titanfall 2 expands that foundation
pilots for example have new abilities
like the grappling hook and Titans now
come in six different flavors all of
which offer distinct ways to play that
demand an almost fighting game like
mastery there's even a brand new
single-player component that delivers
all these ideas in a neat narrative
wrapper and while the writing is
somewhat weak the campaign still rounds
out an already excellent package
dishonor to didn't excel at storytelling
either but it might be the most
mechanically rich game on this list like
titanfall 2 it builds on its predecessor
by refining and expanding existing ideas
ideas like stealthy teleportation and
shadowy dismemberment the suite of
supernatural abilities and inventive
weapons at your disposal allows for a
breathtaking level of lethal creativity
whether you're kicking hapless guards
through skylights or quietly subduing
them from a distance with sleep darts
dishonor to not only accommodate your
choices it adjusts the world and
narrative accordingly mechanically
speaking this might be the single best
example of the choice and consequences
school of game design